Alexandra goujon euh il parle tous les
jours à son peuple ça ça continue ça
c'est une vidéo quasiment tous les soirs
un peu tard vers vers 23h voilà selfie
vidéo dans différents endroits souvent à
l'administration présidentielle et oui
il communique il a besoin de maintenir
le lien aussi sur son action en Ukraine
bien sûr c'est un c'est un communicant
mais il y a d'autres communicants en
Ukraine et les Ukrainiens eux-mêmes sont
des communiquants il y a beaucoup de
choses qui qui circulent sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux donc les Ukrainiens eux
ont besoin d'avoir de l'action qu'est-ce
qu'il fait au concret ah oui il se
déplace c'est pour obtenir des armes et
là-dessus on le suit on est d'accord
voilà lorsqu'il y a un scandale de
corruption faut quand même un moment
donné qui se légitime donc en fait la
vie politique continue oui vivre la
démocratie ukrainienne malgré le
c'est c'est un vrai un vrai souci parce
que aujourd'hui il y a un marathon
télévisuel par exemple qui uniformise
les informations alors que l'Ukraine
était un pays où il y avait des talk
shows avec des députés tous les soirs
qui duraient des heures et qui sont
regardés il y a une vraie animation
politique le journaliste d'investigation
continue c'est extrêmement important les
journalistes qui on va dire ce sont
adaptés à la guerre dans les premiers
mois on continue travail et certains ils
le disent dans plusieurs interviews ont
vu des schémas de corruption et ce sont
dit on ne peut pas laisser passer ça
c'est à dire que le les réformes qui ont
été engagées notamment
depuis la Révolution Maidan depuis 2014
il faut absolument qu'on continue il y a
de l'argent qui va venir de l'Union
européenne il y a de l'argent pour la
reconstruction il y a plus d'argent pour
l'armée il faut qu'on s'assure que tout
cela soit bien utilisé il y a des
garde-fous il y a du contre-pouvoir il y
a aussi toute cette question de la
corruption dans la justice et d'ailleurs
on en a un petit peu moins parlé mais
aujourd'hui en fait et bien lors de la
visite de byden les associations de
lutte contre la corruption on dit voilà
ça va être l'occasion de reparler aussi
de sujets sensibles parce qu'on attend
le directeur du bureau national pour la
lutte contre la corruption on attend sa
nomination et la venue de Biden peut
nous aider donc en fait sur l'aspect
j'allais dire des réformes politiques en
tous les cas
bien sûr il est pris j'allais dire entre
deux types de pression à la fois la
société toute la société civile qui
s'est constituée depuis 2014 et qui
regarde toujours avec un air suspicieux
ces élites politiques on ne sait jamais
ce qu'ils peuvent faire combien même on
les suit sur une partie du chemin et
c'est ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui et puis
bien évidemment les bailleurs de fonds
étrangers qui font aussi pression sur le
sur le pouvoir politique mais c'est vrai
que c'est une démocratie en guerre c'est
une démocratie électorale les prochaines
élections étaient prévues législatives
en octobre 2023 la loi martiale
aujourd'hui elle peut être modifiée mais
interdit tout type de scrutin de
d'élection ou de ou de référendum
[Musique]